The nervous system
is fundamentally electric.
When we move our arm,
it moves because a signal
has been sent to the muscle
that controls it,
and that message
is made of charged atoms
moving in and out
of nerve cells.
It's electricity.
Now, because the brain
is electric,
we could also use
electricity to record
what the brain is doing
or bypass it entirely,
-and control a body.
-[beep]
That means that
we could use our minds
to move other people's bodies,
restore movement to people
who are paralyzed,
feel through an artificial hand
as if it was our own,
and even read people's minds.
Shocking!
[theme music playing]
Even though electricity
wasn't really understood
until the 1800s,
its ability
to influence the body
had been known since at least
ancient Roman times,
when respected physician
Scribonius Largus
wrote about a man
who accidentally stepped
on an electric fish
and was suddenly relieved
of gout pain.
Scribonius did some experiments
and found that you could put
an electric fish
on your head
and relieve headaches.
In 1804,
centuries later,
Italian physicist
Giovanni Aldini
discovered he could make
people's muscles move
with electricity.
He amazed the European world
by using electricity
to animate the corpse
of an executed criminal.
The corpse opened its eyes
and even seemed to sit up.
But Aldini wasn't just
trying to shock people.
He was showing the world
that neurons,
the cells that control both
our thoughts and our movements,
operate through electricity.
[buzzing]
Imagine bypassing
a person's brain
so as to control their body.
Now normally
when you move your body,
your brain sends
electrical signals
through nerves.
But if we could use electrodes
to send those signals,
we could control
a person's body
without needing their brain
to be involved.
We could control them
with a remote control,
and that's what
we are about to do today
with cockroaches.
I'm here with Tim Marzullo
from Backyard Brains,
and, Tim, you brought
some cockroaches.
[Tim] Yes, Michael,
cockroaches use their antenna
to sense their environment
and move around,
and we're going to try
to trick the cockroach
and control
its movement
for a number
of minutes.
Trick it, how do we trick it?
We are going to do a surgery
on the cockroach
where we're going to hijack
the nervous system
to send electrical impulses
to their antenna.
[Michael] All right,
well, let's get to it.
-[Tim] Let's do it.
-[Michael] I've brought with me
today a state-of-the-art
cockroach operating room.
Now, how do you do surgery
on a cockroach?
We have a jar of ice water,
and to induce anesthesia
we are going to put
the cockroaches
in the ice water
and their nervous system
will stop firing
electrical impulses.
We'll notice after a minute
or two they'll stop moving.
[Michael] Once the roaches
were anesthetized,
they were ready
for surgery.
[Tim] All right,
so then now what we're gonna do
is attach the electrodes.
So here we have
the little connector.
It has three wires.
It has a ground wire,
and it has a wire
for the left antenna
and the right antenna.
I'm going to put
a little bead of Superglue
on the cockroach right here,
and then I'm just gonna
stick the electrode
on the cockroach's head.
[Michael] Next,
we inserted the ground wire
into the flight muscle
of the wing.
-[Tim] There you go.
-[Michael] Cool.
[Tim] I put the wire
in the back.
[Michael]
The remaining two wires
get inserted
into the antenna.
[Tim] Now I'm just
gonna snip the antenna
right there and we...
[Michael] And now because
it's a hollow tube...
...we can stick
the wire in.
[Tim] So now,
what I'm gonna do
is I'm just gonna insert it
into the antenna.
-All right?
-[Michael] Got it, wow.
[Tim] And he's ready
for the left antenna.
There we go.
It went right in there.
I'll put the cockroach
right back in the ice water.
Now it's worth pointing out
what this does to them
and to their quality of life.
[Tim] Yeah, after the surgery
I'm gonna take them back
to their homes,
snip the wires,
and these cockroaches
will then be retired.
[Michael] And the antenna
will grow back?
[Tim] Yes, and I will return
them to our reproducing colony,
and they'll live happy
cockroach lives
after the show.
-[Michael] Fantastic.
-[Tim] All right.
-So now we're ready to go.
-[Michael] Wonderful.
Our cyber-roach
was now neurologically wired
for external control.
[Michael] This is
a state-of-the-art
roach racetrack.
Tim and I are about
to take some robo-roaches
for a test drive.
But first, Tim,
I wanna see how
an ordinary roach
moves around
and uses its antenna.
[Tim] So let's just see
where this guy goes.
He wants to explore my hand.
All right,
and then, oh wow.
-Wow.
-Racin' away.
And you can you see
he's hugging that wall.
You can see he keeps tapping
the wall and moving along.
He's not in the middle
of the road,
-he's on the edge of it.
-[Michael] Yeah.
As we know,
roaches use their antennas
to explore their surroundings
and locate food and shelter.
When no walls or obstacles
were sensed,
the roaches felt free
to move around at will.
-Hey, guys...
-[Tim] Hey, whoa, whoa.
[Michael] follow the rules.
It was time to test-drive
our robo-roach.
[Michael] So this
is the battery,
along with
the Bluetooth device.
[Tim] And I'm just gonna plug
them in right now.
[Michael] We're talking
about actual voltages.
[Tim] Yes, because
we are talking to the nerves
in a language that
the nerves understand.
[Michael] Tim has built an app
that communicates
to the electrode
on the roach's back.
When we swipe right,
the electrode sends a signal
to the roach's left antenna,
stimulating the sensation
of an obstacle
on its left
which causes the roach
to move right and vice versa.
Which way should we go,
left or right?
I think we should go left.
Left. Whoa.
-[Tim] Okay, well, that's...
-[Michael] Doing donuts.
All right, that was
a little bit too high.
[Michael] We adjusted
the intensity of the signal
to find the optimal setting.
All right, now, I'm gonna try
to get him to turn right,
go back through the factory.
-[Tim] Oh.
-[Michael] Good job.
-[Tim] Okay, very good.
Now he doesn't know
if there's a road,
so I'm gonna have to tell him
to kind of keep going
-to the right, good.
-[Tim] Okay, very good.
-[Michael]
Yeah, good, come here.
-All right, where is he?
Did he just-- he wants to go
to the hot air balloon?
He wants to go
to the hot air balloon,
but I would rather
he go to work
at the factory,
so I'm gonna-- I'm gonna...
He's like,
"I'll go back to work."
[Michael] I'm gonna swipe left.
-[Tim] Okay.
-There, good. All right, left.
-[Tim] Very good.
-[Michael] Now right.
-[Tim] Ooh. All right.
-[Michael] Good.
-[Michael] All right,
watch this. And turn right.
-[Tim] Okay.
[Michael] Good, good, good.
Turn right.
[Tim] All right,
turns a little bit.
-[Michael] Turn right, oh.
-[Tim] Oh, you see
-he adapts over time.
-[Michael] He adapts over time.
So we are taking away
their autonomous control
of their body.
We're just causing
them to think
they should decide to move
one way or the other.
[Tim] Yeah, some people
used to be sort of scared
that we're on
the slippery slope
where I'm gonna control
a whole humanity
with my electrical stimulation,
but you can see that
there's so many other sensory
signals that the cockroach
is receiving,
that we're competing with.
-So, Tim, this was very cool...
-[Tim] Uh-huh.
-a little bit weird.
I didn't feel
totally comfortable
controlling
a living organism.
-Uh-huh.
-But there's something here
that's, that's really
important for the future
of understanding brains.
[Tim] Sure,
we use this technology
in biomedical applications,
such as cochlear implants,
and deep brain stimulation
to treat Parkinson's.
But things such as
consciousness and attention
and will are currently
really at the cutting edge
of neuroscience research.
How do you
make decisions?
The wonderful thing
about, uh,
neuroscience is
that it's wide open.
[Michael]
In the very near future,
cyber cockroaches
could actually save lives.
Researchers at Texas A&M
and North Carolina
State University
are developing
a groundbreaking use
for robo-roaches in search
and rescue missions.
Instead of installing wires
in the roach's antennae,
they're implanting receptors
in the bug's
actual nervous systems
to insure
a longer-term effect.
The plan is to release
a swarm of robo-roaches
into a disaster area
like a collapsed building.
As the roaches explore,
they'll send images
and data back to a computer
which creates a detailed 3D map
of the disaster zone.
If the cyber-bugs stray
from the search area,
their nerves get stimulated
to steer them back in.
If a roach detects a survivor,
a signal is sent back
with the victim's location.
While a real world test
has not been done yet,
scientists hope to do so
within the next 10 years.
Meanwhile, the same technology
used to cyber-hack cockroaches
can also be used on humans.
Now, Tim,
when I move my arm,
my brain is sending
electrical signals
to my muscles
and they respond to that,
and they contract,
and they release.
But you are about
to use a battery
to electrically
stimulate my muscles.
Sure, sure.
[Michael] A human's
nervous system can be hacked
with no surgery required.
Tim attached electrodes
to my forearm,
which communicated
via Bluetooth
to an app on his iPad.
[Tim] So I'm gonna amplify
the signals
of your muscle activity.
So, every time a neuron
talks to the muscle,
the muscle fires
an electrical impulse
like the neurons.
So we can see
these electrical impulses
right here.
So what I want you to do
-is contract.
-[Michael grunts] Oh, yeah.
[Tim] All right,
so there you go,
you can see the impulses
-occurring in your...
-Watch this.
[Tim] So that whoosh
is the sound
of many muscle
fibers firing...
-[Michael] Many, many.
-firing action potentials
because neurons are synapsing
on those muscles
when you are deciding
to move your body.
Let me passively move
your hand.
We don't see that much activity,
maybe some stretch activity,
but now resist me.
-Now there's no movement...
-[Michael] Wow.
but we're seeing
electrical activity
because it's due
to contraction.
So what's cool
about this
is that because
you are making
voluntary movements
with your brain,
we can exploit these
muscle contractions
and use it
to control robotics.
[Michael] Okay, so, Tim,
this is all really cool,
but the real reason
I invited you here today
and told you to bring
all of this is that
I want to control
another human. Alie?
-Hi, Michael.
-Thanks for coming.
So, Alie, you might be
a little apprehensive now
after hearing
what I just said, but...
Yeah, yeah, I heard you.
This is for science,
and it's gonna go both ways.
I'm gonna let you control
my arm as well. You ready?
Okay. Wait, I'm going
first, though?
You're gonna go first,
I think that's important, yes.
-For...
-For randomization.
-[Alie] Okay.
-I flipped a coin earlier
that no one saw,
but it happened.
Alie Ward
from the Ologies podcast
was brave enough to let me test
how the brain sends signals
to the body,
in this case
my brain sending signals
to move her body.
And we've placed
a screen between us
so she can't see
when I make a move
that sends the signal.
All right, let's do it.
So, Michael.
Okay. Should I contract
like softly or firmly?
-Just go all the way
like that, yes.
-All the way?
-Okay, here we go.
-All right.
-Did you feel anything?
-Not yet, no.
-I'm not strong enough.
-Okay, I'm gonna turn it up
-a little bit, okay?
-[Alie] Okay, yeah.
It feels like pins and needles
a little bit.
[Tim] Okay. You're at two.
I'm gonna turn up to four, okay?
-[Alie] All right.
-Okay.
Now contract,
Michael.
Ah!
That was really, really,
really weird.
-[Tim] Contract.
-Oh, that's really weird.
-[Tim] Okay.
-This is really weird.
Oh, that's-- I'd--
I'm still not over that.
It feels like, uh,
I'm a marionette
and there's just strings
being tugged.
[Michael] For the sake
of science, it was only fair
that I give Alie a turn
at the controls.
But I also wanted to know
what it was like
to have someone
control my movements.
All right, now while
Alie controls my body,
I thought it would be nice
to maybe enjoy some hot,
bright-red tomato soup
and a nice glass
of grape juice.
I might even do some writing,
[scoffs] multitasking.
So, um, can we try out
the strength,
uh, just, like, get
a bit of a sense
-of what's gonna happen to me?
-All right.
So, I'll put it
really low at a two.
-[Michael] Good, yeah.
-[Tim] Okay.
And, uh, okay,
now contract, Alie.
All right.
-Ah, okay, yup, I felt it.
-Contract again.
-I felt...
-Okay. Did you feel that?
-Yes.
-[Tim] All right, now,
I'm gonna turn it up
to a four.
Okay.
All right,
now contract.
-You ready?
-Yup.
[laughter]
Wow.
That's, um,
that's not me moving my arm.
Or the rest of your
entire body responds.
[Michael] Well-- yeah,
I'm a jumpy person,
so you're gonna get
a lot more out of me.
-Okay.
-[Michael] Now, please
don't control me
while I just take a nice,
relaxing sip of...
[Alie chuckles]
[Tim] I'll turn it up
to five and a half.
[Michael] Okay, I'm just
gonna take a nice little,
uh, taste of this soup.
This is so mean.
I love it. [chuckles]
The meanest part is that
this is very lukewarm soup.
All right. Now, just let me
please eat in peace.
-I'm sorry.
-[Michael] All right,
I'm gonna take a break
and write something.
I'll leave you alone,
I'll leave you alone.
Okay.
[groans]
I'm try--
I can resist it, but...
Like the cockroaches,
my body was learning
to adapt to the signal.
To science.
That's the beauty
of electrophysiology.
Of course the fact that our
neurons
work through electricity
means that we can also
record from them,
and that has amazing
medical applications.
The electroencephalogram,
or EEG,
came about in the 1920s,
allowing doctors to see
some of the brain's
electrical signals
as visible brain waves.
But by the 1980s,
scientists realized
that for some tasks,
like the dream of allowing
paralyzed patients
to move a robotic arm,
you need a much richer
brain signal.
That's because moving an arm
requires a lot of information.
You need information
for how to move your upper arm,
your forearm, your hand,
your fingers,
all through 3D space.
EEG just doesn't carry enough
information to do that,
since the electrical signals
it picks up
get distorted
after they make their way
through our skull and skin.
So, if you wanted to control
a prosthetic limb
with just your mind,
researchers realized
you'd need to record
directly from the brain.
And in 2006,
scientists finally
did just that.
They implanted an electrode
in the brain
of a paralyzed human
for the very first time.
And since that
first test patient,
several paralyzed patients
have received brain implants
that allow them
to control robotic arms
with their minds.
As our understanding
of the brain grows
and our computers get better
at decoding signals
from the brain,
these patients are gaining
finer and finer control
over these robotic arms.
Recently, science has taken
a big leap forward
from allowing
paralyzed patients
to control robotic limbs
to giving them control
of their own limbs.
I traveled
to Ohio State University
to meet one of those patients,
Ian Burkhart.
At 19, while vacationing
with friends,
Ian dove into a wave
at the beach
and broke his neck
on the sandy floor,
leaving him paralyzed
from the chest down.
[Ian] I knew as soon as I hit
that I was paralyzed.
And I was floating
face-down in the water
-and could not get up.
-Could you...
[Ian] I couldn't move
anything at all.
You go from being 19
and independent,
living on your own
in college, to now.
I need help doing everything
from eating to going
to the bathroom,
sitting up,
getting into my wheelchair.
I can move my shoulders
pretty well,
can move my biceps
that allow me
to move my arms
a little bit,
but nothing
from my biceps down.
[Michael] The doctors
at Ohio State had approached
Ian about a revolutionary
experimental treatment
developed by Battelle,
a research
and development firm
using cutting-edge technology
called NeuroLife.
They wanted to implant a chip
in Ian's motor cortex,
which would allow him
to move his hand again
while he was connected
to a computer in the lab.
I was invited
to the Wexner Medical Center
at Ohio State University
to meet the researchers
and witness this cutting-edge
work in action.
[Sam] So first we're gonna plug
Ian into the system.
[Ian] The piece, uh, is
protruding from my skull as...
-[Michael] Yeah.
-[Ian] ...reference,
that's the pedestal.
It's under
a little protective cap,
um, but it's there 24/7
and it leads to some wires
that go to the actual
microchip array
that's on the surface
of my brain.
[Michael] Pushed into
the actual organ of the brain.
[Ian] Exactly.
[Michael]
The microchip in Ian's head
detects the blood flow
and electrical impulses
of his brain
that are associated
with causing movement.
[Sam]
So this is the actual chip.
It sits on the surface
of his brain.
[Michael] Wow.
Ian's brain is connected
to software
that reads and analyzes
his brain activity.
So this is a live look
at Ian's motor cortex.
[Marcie] Yes.
So if you think about
moving your arm,
we should see more activity
-or a different pattern?
-[Ian] Yeah.
[Michael]
At the start of the session,
in order to calibrate
the decoder with his brain,
Ian is prompted
to think about
moving his hand
by watching images
of hand movements.
[Ian] You'll see
my computer prompt me
and as it prompts me
to do that,
that's what
I'm thinking about.
What do you mean
"think about?"
[Ian] Just as much
as I can think about
-imagining that movement.
-Yeah.
As Ian's brain thinks
about moving his hand...
-[Sam] Okay, Ian, are you ready?
-Yup.
[Michael]
...its electrical signals
are detected by the chip
and sent to the decoder.
Then we take
that information
and we associate it
with a hand closed.
So now the decoder
can recognize
if he's thinking
that same thing again.
[Michael] Next,
the decoder sends a signal
to a device that can control
Ian's muscle movement.
This special sleeve
on Ian's arm
contains a hundred
and thirty electrodes,
which stimulate the muscles
in his forearm
to produce the specific
movements
that his brain
is thinking about,
such as closing his hand
or moving his thumb.
Now it was time to see Ian
move his paralyzed hand
with his thoughts.
[Sam] So, Ian, if you're ready
for this next one...
-[Ian] Yup.
-I'm gonna count you down.
Three, two, one.
[Michael] Whoa.
[Marcie] So,
that was the decoder.
Decoding his thoughts?
-Decoding his thoughts.
-[Michael] Wow.
[Marcie] Ian was in control
of the movements.
[Michael] Nice work.
Already, Ian's achievements
go far beyond
closing his hand.
With the help of this
cutting-edge technology,
he can use
his own paralyzed hand
to do a number
of fine motor tasks
from everyday movements
to playing Guitar Hero.
How many other people
are like Ian?
Currently in the world,
maybe five?
[Michael] Ian continues
to gain more independence
outside the lab, as well.
Do people
ever drive with you
and get nervous like,
"Oh, my gosh,
well, clearly
this is dangerous."
[Ian] I think
if everyone else
that was driving
along in the road knew
I have no use of my hands
going 70 miles an hour
down the freeway,
they may not like that.
But they've-- they have
nothing to worry about.
[Ian] Right, yeah,
and I'm probably safer
because I can't take
my hands off the wheel
-to get on my cell phone and...
-Right. Yup.
You're not fiddling
with the radio and...
Yeah, that I shouldn't be
doing while I'm driving.
[Michael] Ian's progress
was truly inspiring,
and this was only
the beginning for him.
What are your hopes
for the future for yourself?
[Ian] Hopefully,
I can upgrade
to the next version
and, you know,
have more capabilities
and be able to do things
a lot easier.
In the long term, I hope
that this can be a device
that people just use.
You have someone
who has a spinal cord injury
and they can just continue
right where they left off.
I think, you know,
the work that we're doing
is something that has
never been done before
and it's really exciting to be
on that cutting edge.
Restoring movement
is one thing,
but what about feeling,
sensation?
We feel with our skin
because of signals
sent to the somatosensory
cortex of our brain.
By putting sensors
in robotic fingers
connected to implants
in a person's
somatosensory cortex,
researchers
at the University of Pittsburgh
have enabled Nathan Copeland
to feel
through a robotic hand.
Nathan underwent
brain surgery
to receive two implants,
one in his motor cortex
to control a robotic arm
and a second implant
over his somatosensory cortex.
This second implant
stimulates his brain
and the pattern
of stimulation depends
on what part
of the robot hand is touched.
So, if you touch the robot
on a specific finger,
then the part of Nathan's
somatosensory cortex
that normally responds
to that finger
get stimulated.
[Nathan] Pinky.
Uh, middle.
[Michael] His brain interprets
that as touch.
Nathan and Ian's
remarkable achievements
have been aided
by their ability
to communicate
with the researchers involved.
But what can be done
for people
who are not only
unable to move,
but also unable to speak?
Steve Kaplan was an active
57-year-old computer programmer
dating Laurie,
a horse wrangler
for the rodeo.
But that all changed
a year ago
when he suffered
a massive stroke
leaving him
in a vegetative state,
unable to move or speak.
Doctors initially declared
Steve brain dead.
However, inside his body
he was fully conscious,
but unable to tell them so.
It wasn't
until a nurse noticed
that Steve's eye movements
were intentional
that he was diagnosed
with locked-in syndrome,
a condition which robs
people of everything
but their mind.
While a normal brain
receives electrical signals
from the senses and sends
signals back to them,
the stroke prevented
the electrical signals
from leaving Steve's brain.
Over the last year,
with the help
of physical therapists,
Steve has regained
some very minor
range of motion in his neck.
I sat down with Steve
and his now-wife Laurie
to learn more about
locked-in syndrome.
Steve, Laurie, hello.
Although he's still
unable to speak,
thanks to new scientific
developments,
Steve can communicate
with the outside world
using a computer.
[computer male voice]
Hello, Michael.
[Michael]
Nice to meet you, Steve.
And nice
to meet you, Laurie.
First of all,
thank you so much
for giving us some time.
Tell me how Steve started
being able to communicate.
[Laurie] Well, you know,
I asked a lot of questions
about locked-in syndrome
when they explained
what it was,
and there wasn't
a lot of answers.
-Yeah.
-[Laurie] At the beginning,
he would blink once for yes
and twice for no.
And that was the first parts
of the communication.
And then they
gave us a board,
and I went
through the ABCs,
and he would close his eyes
when I got to what he wanted.
I'd write it down,
and that's how it began.
[Michael] As you could imagine,
Laurie and Steve's
first method of communicating
was a slow
and painstaking process.
But just months later,
an engineer working to help
locked-in patients
built Steve a machine
that tracks his eye movements.
As Steve looks at different
letters on a screen,
the machine translates
where he's looking
into synthesized
audible speech.
[computer male voice]
I want to recover.
[Michael] Although
there's still a slight delay
in communication
as Steve scans
the letters on the screen,
this method is much more fluid
and significantly faster.
The computer helps me
communicate
[Michael] Yeah.
You can write with your eyes.
[Laurie]
This thing's amazing.
He can email,
he can text,
call me
if he needs something.
It's such a relief.
[computer male voice]
It does wonders.
[Michael]
It does wonders, yes.
-Uh-hmm, [chuckles]
-[Michael] And I could only
imagine how emotional
it would have been
to you to be able to look
and write a thing,
and then have it spoken.
And, Laurie,
for you to hear
words coming from his mind,
from his heart,
especially
for the first time
-in a long time.
-[Laurie] Yes.
What was the first thing
you said, Steve?
[computer male voice] The first
message was happy birthday.
[laughter]
What a birthday present.
[Laurie laughs]
It really was.
[Michael] Steve's progress
is remarkable,
and it would be
difficult to deny
the connection between
his new ability to communicate
and connect
with the outside world
with the incredible advances
he's made physically
over the last year.
-Look up at the ceiling.
-[Michael] Yeah.
-Look down at your thumbs.
-[clears throat]
Look over at me,
your beautiful wife.
[laughter]
[Michael] Laurie and Steve
hope that one day
Steve will make
a full recovery
from locked-in syndrome.
Steve's eye-tracking device
is electric,
and so is his brain.
They're connected by the fact
that Steve can move his eyes.
But some locked-in patients
can't even control
their eye movements.
They have what is known
as completely
locked-in syndrome.
For these patients,
the eye-tracking technology
that helped Steve communicate
is useless.
But researchers in Europe
recently found a way
of allowing completely
locked-in patients
to communicate
using just their thoughts.
The researchers combined EEG
with near-infrared
spectroscopy,
which can non-invasively
measure blood flow
in the brain.
The patients were asked
simple yes or no questions
that the researchers
knew the answers to,
which allowed them
to train a machine to recognize
which brain signals meant yes
and which brain signals
meant no.
The researchers
then asked the patients
a new set of questions
they knew the answer to,
and using just their thoughts,
the patients were able to give
the correct answers
to 70% of the questions.
Now, giving just
yes or no answers
may be limited,
but this technology is new.
All of this happened
just this year.
These rapid advancements,
thanks to the devotion
and effort of researchers
and subjects around the world,
are slowly but surely
chipping away
at the mysteries of the mind.
The better
we understand the mind,
the better
we'll be able to help
the millions of people
who struggle to do
what they want
because of psychological
or neurological conditions,
and ultimately the better
we'll understand ourselves.
And as always,
thanks for watching.
[theme music playing]